les maires de normandie réuni autour de
lui se sont levés pour l'applaudir alors
est ce que c'est un tournant en tout cas
il y en a un qui a retrouvé la pêche
qu'elle avait peut-être un peu besoin
c'est benjamin griveaux le porte parole
du gouvernement pour lui oui ça c'est
vraiment très bien passé
hier on a observé je crois l'ouverture
narré à l'acte 2 du quinquennat et ce
travail d'écouté va nous permettre
d'écrire aussi la suite de ce récit
national
je crois que on a invité tous nos
concitoyens à participer que c'était un
beau débat d'ouverture hier et pour
ouvrir le débat opposant tendre à un
autre point de vue évidemment un peu
différent sinon c'est pas intéressant
c'est celui de thierry mariani vous
savez cet ancien ministre de l'ump qui
vient de rallier le rassemblement
national et qui sera sur la liste de ce
parti aux prochaines européennes
pour lui ça n'était que du spectacle
regardez d'abord pour la durée on est
dans le spectacle vous savez il avait
fait 10 heures je viens de vérifier 10
heures au salon de l'agriculture pour
être celui qu'elle avait fait le plus
long à cette heure avec les maires je
rappelle simplement et tout le monde l'a
oublié qui à un mois et demi il a refusé
d'aller au congrès des maires alors
qu'il l'avait annoncé avant donc on a en
réalité un président qui se rend compte
qu'il fait fausse route et qui va en
rajouter ensuite est-ce que ça va
déboucher sur quelque chose je le
souhaite mais je fais le parallèle avec
le salon de l'agriculture il restait dix
heures il ya aucune mesure us qui a été
prise après donc bon l'exercice vous
entendez quoi je suis en tant que c'est
un show voilà point final philippe et
bien c'était un show où il s'est passé
quelque chose quand même il a été bon il
connaît bien ses dossiers il va être élu
vous allez voir qu'il va être élu c'est
continue la campagne comme ça ça va se
terminer à l'elysée sans aucun doute
après des ordres ils vont commencer et
lui d'abord meilleure façon vous dites
que l'histoire bégaye non je dis qu'il
ya quand on dit il ya un tournant
il y en a à mon avis est
incontestablement un mais c'est pas un
tournant on sait pas une épingle à
cheveux ce pas un tournant qu'il faut
prendre à 90 à l'heure ni même à 80 mais
c'est un tournant qui est fait à la fois
de ceux qui ont envie que ça se termine
en tout cas que ça aboutisse à des
choses qui calme le jeu que la crise des
gilets jaunes des termites et
effectivement les maires me paraissent
content de pouvoir reprendre la main
mais c'est aussi un tournant qui est dû
au fait que le
mouvement des gilet jaune lui même est
en train d'évoluer qu'il essaye en
partie de s'organiser qu'il a épuré ou
qu'il ait said épuré en partie ses
propres rangs on voit bien que ceux des
gilet jaune qui était le plus proche de
du rassemblement national le sont en
train de se faire marginaliser en tout
cas qu'un certain nombre d'autres j'ai
déjà on essaie de les marginaliser
il se passe quelque chose le tournant
encore une fois je le crois faible mais
il existe la sortie on est en train de
sortir de la crise
je crois que c'est précipité de le dire
il est certain que c'est une mise en
scène une représentation de la grande
réconciliation que qu'emmanuel macron
avait déjà initié quand même à plusieurs
reprises dans ses discours précédents il
n'est jamais aussi bon que dans ce genre
de l'exercice un peu un showman gold
c'est vrai qu'il a réussi à retourner la
salle donc c'est son grand talent et en
même temps c'est un personnage qui est
très surprenant parce qu'il est capable
aussi d'avoir des sorties comme ya
quelques jours auront la galette des
rois qui vont alors là à la rencontre
des aux préoccupations des gens du
peuple pour reprendre ce terme là donc
c'est un personnage quand même assez
assez surprenant je pense que en tout
cas les mères effectivement semble avoir
été assez convaincu je pense que c'est
assez salutaire qu'elle tende la
bouderie et puis il ya le temps aussi de
l'esprit de responsabilité
les mairies peuvent jouer un rôle
absolument crucial dans cette
consultation dans cette république de
délibération permanente
qu'appelle de ses voeux emmanuel macron
et son mouvement des gilet jaune à
l'intérêt justement de braquer le
projecteur sur les communes qui sont en
fait des échelons essentiel dans la dans
la république depuis la révolution et
finalement elles ont été assez pas
laminer mais disons très éclipsé par
tout ce après après la seconde guerre
mondiale après tout ce mouvement de
reconstruction de la france de
modernisation et ensuite d'aménagement
du territoire
et là ils reviennent oui et on sort on
se retrouve là avec finalement c'est la
revanche un peu des communes et il a
fini emmanuel macron par le comprendre
je pense qu'il était temps de là à dire
que c'est un tournant je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'il en fasse plus d'accord
alors d'ailleurs nos
un internaute sur twitter soit assez
dubitatif fait intéressant vous a posé
la question est ce que ce grand parce
que cette intervention devant les maires
est un tournant dans le quinquennat a
lancé carrément ouailles on a 45% quand
même qu'ils considèrent que oui ce qui
est une minorité mais quand même une
minorité influente et vous jacques de
guillebon à ce que vous avez été bluffé
par le chef de l'état hier comme tout le
monde le fait par le comédien aux grands
comédiens qu'il est je pense qu'il va
être nominé aux oscars et aux césars
pardon excusez moi je pense c'est simple
ils montrent qu'il est le plus grand
comédien de france encore une fois ça
c'était assez impressionnant sinon le
virage où le tournant s'il y en a on
peut dire clairement
déjà au mois de décembre où il a fait
son discours à 12 milliards là où il
avait déjà commencé à reculer
annonçant la première fois en fait là
c'est un petit tournant mais il a fait
un exercice de des couteaux de ce doux
écoute auprès des maires où il a
réaffirmé que c'était sa ligne qui
allait continuer il a il n'a rien donné
j'ai l'impression pour l'instant il a
dit qu'il les écouter je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient un tournant il est plutôt
en campagne de nous l'avait dit mais de
mi mandat si on peut dire que comme
s'ils avaient des midterm c'est en
france qu'il serait né des européennes
là pour essayer de se refaire une
légitimité et je pense qu'on aura droit
pendant trois mois jusqu aux européennes
donc à une campagne fait aimer le
maquereau aux frais de la république
pour pour gagner les européennes au fait
justement est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
problème de d'interlocuteurs j smadja
parce que en fait ces mères qui était
très à l'écouté qui ont semble-t-il
était assez convaincu parce qu'à dix
fonctionnaires publics se sont pas eux
les gilet jaune en fait donc c'est
peut-être pas vu qu'il fallait en
premier lieu convaincre à moins qu il
fallait qu à moins qu il fallait qu il
fallait qu il eût fallu commencer par le
voilà c'est thomas philippe meyer parce
que pour moi c'est le journaliste qui
parle le mieux le français à la radio
donc même si j'ai eu tort il me le dit
pas c'est gentil ce qui est intéressant
dans ce qui s'est passé hier c'est que
les communes les maires ont été remis au
centre de la république sont ils ont été
désignés comme des piliers de notre
démocratie
après avoir été quand même largement
décrié pendant toute une période
il dépensait trop l'argent public il ne
faisait pas attention leurs moyens n'ont
cessé de diminuer au cours des dernières
années à tel point qu'il y a un maire
sur deux qui envisage de ne pas se
représenter aux prochaines élections
municipales
tellement c'est dur aujourd'hui de
de diriger une commune alors donc on le
redécouvre aujourd'hui toute une série
de vertueux mais là où vous avez raison
de pointer ce problème c'est que en fait
hier il n'y a pas eu de tournant sur le
fond il y a eu un exercice de d'une
volonté du président de la république de
montrer qu'ils connaissaient les
problèmes qu'ils connaissaient les
dossiers qu'il n'était pas ce président
autun loin des préoccupations qu'on
avait pu décrire mais sur le fond il n'a
absolument rien lâcher il n'a rien lâché
sur le retour de leur établissement de
l'impôt sur la fortune
il n'a rien lâché sur l'augmentation des
bas salaires
il n'a rien lâché sur le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
c'est une formidable capacité à
mémoriser les ficher les notes que lui
prépare ses collaborateurs ça c'est vrai
il faut le reconnaître il a un certain
talent pour ça mais il n'a il n'a pas
annoncé de choses qui sont susceptibles
de faire sortir de nous faire sortir de
la crise dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui et alors vous qui connaissez
parfaitement ce sujet puisque vous êtes
le plus proche collaborateur d'un maire
vous avez été impressionné par sa
maîtrise technique des dossiers parce
que les mères lui poser des questions
parfois qui était compliqué on avait
même au même à l'oral de lennar vous en
fausses pages aussi de ses pointus il
faut il faut lui reconnaître ce talent à
bien connaître le contenu des dossiers
c'est à dire leur contexte les
législations d'où ça vient quel est le
problème posé
mais par contre dès qu'il s'agit
d'apporter des réponses concrètes des
solutions là il est tout de suite
beaucoup plus un hasard quand un maire
lui dit mais il faut pas fermer la
maternité qui a parce que si vous fermez
la maternité qui à côté de ma commune à
ce moment là il va falloir faire une
heure de route pour trouver une
maternité l'aï dit mais non on peut pas
faire autrement quand on est maire lui
pose la question des contrats aidés qui
ont été supprimées par emmanuel macron
et du coup ça eu des tas de conséquences
pour les clubs sportifs pour les
associations
là il dit pas jouer les rétablir voyez
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois quand même
au moment où on arrive au point le plus
important c'est à dire la réponse
la solution là il n'est pas présent et
et on voit bien que les décisions les
choix qu'il a faits au depuis le début
du quinquennat il n'entend pas y
renoncer pour le moment
petite remarque marginal mais vous avez
vu les vues d'ensemble des mères ils ont
tous les cheveux gris quand ils ont
encore des cheveux je parle pas je parle
des hommes souffrent arrive a dit
l'entraîneur explique le fait qu'ils
vont pas se représenter parce qu'ils
n'ont pas 20 ans c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est quand même une
une image qui traduit le fait que pour
assumer des fonctions municipales
aujourd'hui dans ce pays il faut être
retraités les possibilités qui sont
d'année au maire de se consacrer est de
continuer à gagner honorablement leur
vie sans gagner des milles et des cents
sont extrêmement faibles la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut peut-être pas
exagérer non plus la qualité des mères
en question énormément d'affaires de
corruption sont des affaires qui
concernent des mères souvent bien plus
que des affaires qui concernent des
députés et en plus sur la manière dont
les mères ont dans beaucoup de cas gérer
leurs finances
il ya en effet quelque chose à dire et
puis enfin il ya quand même quelque
chose d'extraordinaire c'est que rien ne
se passe au parlement mais rien
absolument rien alors peut-être
tactiquement c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire d'aller voir les maires pour dire
puisque il est convenu que les maires
sont plus proches de la population que
les autres élus
c'est avec eux que je vais aller parler
enfin en même temps il ya quelque chose
de tout à fait extravagant fait que le
parlement soit à ce point il existe
parce qu'il est plus représentatif en
fait ils parlent de démocratie
délibérative mais le parlement avec ses
400 députés
lauren que personne ne connaît en fait
qu'on est élu dans la suite de
maquereaux n'est pas du tout aux
tentatives du peuple donc ya pas de
débat possible là bas c'est pour ça
qu'il est obligé de sauter d'aller
chercher au plus bas des gens qui
représenterait en fait les français ont
semble-t-il après est-ce que c'est son
rôle d'intervenir tout de suite on parle
à cette question que j'avais pose pas du
tout forcément serre que le rôle du
parlement peut-être à partir justement
de tout ce qu'il a remonté de cette
consultation de ce grand débat national
de traiter ces idées de les mettre en
ordre les synthés lycée et d'en faire
quelque chose qui soit débattue au sein
de l'assemblée
donc c'est peut-être un peu tôt de la
même façon qu'il est peut-être un poteau
de demander à emmanuel macron de
trancher alors qu'il ya deux jours il a
publié une lettre où il dit voilà nous
allons parler de toutes sortes de choses
donc effectivement si déjà ils donnent
la réponse aux grands débats qui dès
qu'ils commencent à peine à couvrir
c'est quand même un peu problématique
dans ce qu'il a fait hier soir poser
l'ensemble en effet mais il peut pas en
tout cas tranché le débat d'un coup deux
jours après ce n'est pas possible qu'on
peut dire ça mais on peut aussi étonné
cette année qu'il n'y ait pas de
gouvernement on peut s'étonner ou poser
la question est ce que c'est à lui de
mes stades où est-ce que c'est au
premier ministre
est ce qu'un gouvernement est ce que ce
gouvernement est autre chose que le
pseudo potes de s'emparer des sujets et
de faire en sorte qu'ils soient
discutées oui il ya pas plus de
gouvernement et d'ailleurs tous les
journaux et tous les commentateurs font
remarquer que les ministres sont deux
glorieuses inconnu et qu'il y en a aucun
sur lequel ils puissent se marier
il y avait les images que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure en commençant du
porte parole du gouvernement entouré de
deux se lient vaut qu'ils font comme les
chiens à l'arrière des voitures
oui oui oui quand le porte parole du
gouvernement voulait pas qu'elle se sent
comme dans ce qu'ils font là si d'autres
at elle expliqué
qu'est ce que c'est que je tiendrais
public et les travers du régime
présidentiel président pas vous laisser
dire ce que vous avez dit sur les
questions de corruption des mères
franchement c'est totalement à côté de
la réalité évoqué le problème de la
corruption des maires comme comme si
c'était un vrai problème alors que ce
sont quelques affaires qui touchent
peut-être moins de 1% des mers et
surtout sur les plus de trente mille
communes qui sont aujourd'hui gérées non
franchement aujourd'hui
croyez moi être maire d'une commune
quelle que soit la notamment les petites
et les moyennes communes c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement difficile et
extrêmement difficile parce que vous
avez de moins en moins de moyens et vous
avez une demande des citoyens qui est de
plus en plus forte
et croyez moi ils ne sont pas du tout
concerné par des affaires de corruption
au contraire que la mairie de mon
village de l'aveyron qui comporte trois
cent cinquante habitants n'a pas
beaucoup les moyens de se lancer dans
des affaires de corruption
il n'empêche qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'affaires de corruption qui
concernaient des maires ça ne veut pas
dire que tous les maires sont corrompus
ça veut dire que on aurait tort d'en
gélizé je voulais entrer les chiens sur
une prochaine fois cible très bien pour
ça et pour ceux qui n'avaient pas la
tribune asco gouvernementale sous les
yeux à côté d'eux du porte parole du
gouvernement il y avait madame poirson
et messieurs le corps nu qui sont des
membres du gouvernement chargés de
coordonner cette manne wargon pardon des
quais tai chi et je me transit de
ministres qui sont tous les deux chargés
au cinéma le nom de figure on arrive
vraiment tout à fait sûr que c'est parce
que c'est moi qui fais mal bon travail
qui aurait dû en parler plus tôt alors
si vous voulez bien on va rester sur